here's a guy right now who gave up on
his dreams to have a child
[Laughter]
look at that kid looks like amy schumer
[Laughter]
dude
yeah like it's about to snitch on a
fellow comedian for something it didn't
do
she must have a lot of room under her
bus
you do not want to be friends with her
because it's coming man yo
[Laughter]
uh it's matthew from canton georgia and
me and my girl have a debate club
we were just watching you guys um
so the power rangers team or
the captain planet team captain planet
has them hearts so our money's on uh
the captain planet team but uh what do
you guys think
gang gang buzz buzz oh dude i know you
look like captain planet but
the power rangers went hard in the pain
thank you when i was a kid
it was all day power rangers mighty
morphis
now it gets a little the new power
rangers are a little weak they're all
politically correct yeah half of them
are women
they made the black ranger not black
anymore yeah no way because that was
racist they made the yellow ranger not
asian like
i guess the black ranger is blue now
he's blue blue yeah he's blue
yeah it's on ouch
both of those suck how about that
my kid's not into that gay [ __ ] bro
yeah yeah man so sting them both
in the debate club what did
what did the guy want to know what was
wrong with that what do you what was
better as a kid
power rangers or captains i never got
into captain i never got there
there's always an agenda even as a kid i
was like what are they trying to sell me
on doug i'm good
yeah it always litter come on yeah it
always felt like it was about litters
or like saving a rain forest or some
kind of [ __ ] or the planet
yeah yeah i'm trying to dude it's
saturday morning
i'm gonna eat my series i'm trying to
watch ren and stimpy animation
fdo half captain planet
what's the yellow thing what's the
yellow thing in his chest a planet oh
what planet captain planet that's a good
point
yeah yeah i don't know what yellow
planet
um but thanks for sending in him man
that's a beautiful child you got your
super cute